what would you have done differently if  you had your life to live all over again  [Music]  I probably would have  charged people more earlier and  because I'm 27 now what I would have  done differently was well you tell  people you're 20.  when I'm younger I'll probably tell  people on 15 13. so I double like I'll  be 20 years old until I'm 13 years old  to get some [ __ ] money because that's  how the life is that's how it works man  just want young women 15 year old girl  would make more money than a 20 year old  yeah I think so  I think if I was 20 years old and I said  I was 15 I was I would definitely make  more money because I feel like more  people would give a 15 year old money  than they would a 20 year old